[Music]
do you have a brother and sister kissing
each other on youtube is it that
christian channel again no oh
what up invaders chris here alright it
is so
good well i mean first of all i see why
no one would see him as a threatening
kiss i have an inkling this guy doesn't
go for the women in the words of ronnie
craig i prefer boys right
yeah yeah you got a lot of balls kids i
prefer boys all right guys i am going to
ask her to try to kiss me honestly he's
standing within like 12 foot of the
woman and you're telling me she can't
hear him spring into the camera
this is the same as me going okay guys
i'm within feet of brian now i'm gonna
ask him to punch me yeah and then you go
yeah exactly it's [__]
i'm so nervous
it's because you're about to kiss your
sister
[__] why are you nervous you're the one
who's just chosen to do this you [__]
you're the social media predator do you
actually think he's really a sister they
do look a bit alive i think it might
just be because he plucks his eyebrows
similar to his sister i can't tell
they look quite into it though do you
know what i mean i mean they're very
into it he's actually touching her now a
lot um well the dog's liking it now
oh i've seen this guy before prank
invasion this guy's a desperate little
creep he's a [__] weirdo turns out he
does a lot of kissing pranks brian yeah
i mean is that his whole channel kissing
pranks uber edition kissing my sister's
best friend high school edition it
basically comes across like no one would
kiss this guy and he's sitting there in
his room at like 18 like how the [__] am
i gonna get people to start kissing me
i'll start
a channel hey guys uh here to teach you
how to kiss women so what you're gonna
need is a camera and you're gonna need
to say it's a prank would you mind
kissing me that's not the way to get
women yeah just to be absolutely clear
not the kind of women you actually want
this is vanity fair no vogue same thing
this is vogue's 73 questions with kim
kardashian
kanye yeah
um i'm here to ask 73 questions i'm
ready
babe
this is for me these are [__] clowns
the world demanded kanye and joe rogan
do a podcast together yeah kanye being
the [__] trick that he is was like oh
we've got to have phone conversations
first we've he needs special [__]
treatment for everything he does and
eventually basically jorgen's come up on
the podcast to me like it's just not
going to happen like he keeps stringing
us along he's never actually going to
get around to it are you angry about
this [__] people around and acting
like you're too good to do a podcast
with joe organ like you're not joe
rogan's done podcasts with people far
greater than kanye west so your home is
clearly stunning thank you how would you
describe this home i would say like a
minimal monastery uh so that's their
bath did you say minimal monastery yeah
minimum minimal yeah minimal let me see
what minimal is show me [__] minimal
right it's basically just lots of lots
of stuff it's the opposite of minimal
then isn't it i was going to say lots of
space yeah yeah and what would you say
is a thing that your kids taught you the
alphabet
well they certainly didn't teach out a
sock
yeah bad idea to involve the kids in
this video the kids are basically
constantly talking throughout it let's
not act like she parents these kids i'm
not being funny it's kind of yeah who
looks after the kids come on when you've
got a performer like kanye and someone
like who's always at fashion week here
in there the real parenting is being
done by paid nannies or chloe chloe's
not got my child son she could get me on
her tell you she's [__] me i think she
probably could because tristan cheated
on her big old thick woman like her i
like yeah but tall and thick you want
like an oak tree not a challenge dude
what i mean
kim you have over 130 million instagram
followers honestly what is that like
it's so crazy just to think about it
clearly the the questions have been put
in later yeah they'll have been read in
and then they'll be reread after yeah
when someone asks you a question no
matter what scenario you have to sit and
go
um you can tell that these are the most
rehearsed [__] answers because there
isn't even a look of surprise on her
face at any point there's no there's no
pause everything is just
saying you wouldn't want vogue magazine
to come and ask you 73 questions no i'm
saying that yes they can get [__] i
literally couldn't give a [__] oh i like
vogue really i don't really know
anything about it
it was a good song but it wasn't
madonna's best no it's true um chinese
medical center have invented a sperm
extracting machine for donors to
masturbate them in the hospital do you
see the yeah i mean the actions if you
feel embarrassed about masturbating in a
hospital you're not going to feel less
embarrassed about putting your penis
into a machine this is useless i mean
that might work well you know what i
mean why i don't know it just looks like
it would be cool i'm sorry you don't
want to use your hand okay shag this
machine for a minute there's a lot of
great things came out of china and this
is just one of the many cost famously
the ipod
um the ipod chicken chow mein chicken
[Laughter]
experiment this man is basically us in
20 years please please join in
let's build something here yeah
comment below
like
subscribe
hit the bell
and i'll see you guys very very soon i
love this card again is this basically
dad does social media is that what we're
looking at pretty much yeah pain don't
last people depression can kiss my ass
hashtag hashtag beastmode i love that
this is just such a cliche like dad
poster playing the guinness starting off
uh away days oh
classic away there he is hunting at the
time you can't
yeah there he is which which means she's
on holiday because you only have spanish
beer yeah on holiday he's really playing
around with filters though
he looks like he's melting literally a
candle of him do it for the holy [__]
do it for the holy [__] you got a heart
i really can't wait for him to go out to
the pub yeah and he sees a girl he
hasn't seen in 10 years
and she looks at him and she goes holy
[__] you got hot and he just goes that's
why i do it that's why that's funny
turbo charged tuesday
i bet he drives a mini cooper happy 55th
birthday to me i mean do you know what
it is right 55 you look scared great
yeah no you just because most 55 year
olds they're fat lumps of [__] and i'll
probably be one myself one day so he's
getting in the gym he's doing it he's
also i rate that i have to say this guy
if you haven't uh if you need someone to
follow you want some inspiration in your
life you want to see what real living is
yeah rick cowley rick dot coley
give him a follow the man's a legend in
other news the new star wars is out i'm
actually quite excited for that the
trailer yeah it looks pretty good it
does and then they're laughing at the
end it's clearly palpatine um well
anyway i don't know anything about it
one guy who definitely isn't and he's
never seen it
mr plenty that's his name never seen
star wars none of them never will oh my
god you're missing out maybe nobody
you're missing out on being a
multi-millionaire wow keep your movie
keep you moving can we just clarify he's
there with a bentley there lovely
bentley it wasn't ever a choice of you
can either be a millionaire or you could
say star wars yeah they're not mutually
exclusive george lucas has seen star
wars i'm pretty sure the people who made
star wars are much more richer they're
so rich
this is him being very cool slim joe you
should call it um wow oh
smoke circles all the time clearly by
the way he's holding it
oh gosh some good cigar smoke
it's really good he just has videos
about himself and he seems quite off his
own ass yeah he's only got he's got
youtube.com hate speech yeah let's go to
his youtube channel another thing
females enjoy is they enjoy managed
successful money's a very easy measure
of success who doesn't and on top of
that the number one thing women want
more than anything is fun i think that's
a that's a big takeaway
you're saying the most basic [__]
women like fun come on guys i've owned
strip clubs i've owned webcam studios at
one point i had a hierarchy i understand
women from the ground up and i don't
just understand women in regards to how
to get them i understand how to retain
them i understand what motivates them i
understand how to make a female happy
he's worked with strippers and webcam
girls and he thinks that that means he
understands women
as a whole i think it's fair to say i
hope you're ground up brian if women
would allow me to speak on behalf of
them that doesn't represent all women
what i do is i retain women not only do
i retain women i train them to be the
way i want them to be i make them
fiercely loyal they allow me to [__]
other women they do anything i say he's
not all kelly you know he just basically
trains women to be brainwashed and
letting them [__] as many women as he
wants and retaining them as objects but
he's not like oh kelly for the first
time doing something i didn't think i'd
do on this youtube i'm going to sell a
course and i'm going to sell the course
on how to get women from the ground up
how to speak to them in the first place
how to approach them what motivates them
what to say how to sleep with them
because that's that's only half the game
no woman with an ounce of common sense
wants anything to do with this [__]
creep try it with condoleezza rice see
how you get on you can convince
condoleezza rice to do that i will ask
all right to buy it at this [__]
yeah yeah yeah tell all right
oh oh how to get girls oh yes i want to
join now 250 this guy is charging for a
pimpin horse degree got the phd program
yesterday great actionable advice
straight to the point
very well explained changes your
attitude and mindset right away 100
recommended now i can walk around with a
renewed sense of confidence attract the
girls that i wanted and punish the
hordes who think they're so big and bad
i'm not the type of person to copy what
anyone else does but i also know an
opportunity when i see one so from that
one you can get true geordie's course on
how to get girls click the link in the
description below just 500 pounds
a month you've got to say you will get
your full guide from the ground up yeah
on how to get girls and also from the
sky down and how because that's
important that is the most important
thing yeah how to retain these [__]
yeah this is the thing is you're not
understanding how these [__] work all
right so i'm going to tell you from the
clouds to the moon
how to get [__] [__]
santa is captured
sky what's interesting about it
basically julian assange was the man
responsible for outing all the
governments as utter [__] they then went
on to just go do we have to do anything
about this just probably lock him up
shall we so then there was a woman who
then accused him of raping her in sweden
he basically said he wouldn't face the
charges because he said that it were
false but secondly he knew that it would
lead to his extradition to the united
states where he could basically be tried
for what they call crimes some people
said he revealed the government what
they were some people said no he wasn't
a prick he was actually a good man he
was then put in the ecuadorian embassy
for seven years because the ecuadorian
government agreed with him a new
ecuadorian government comes in didn't
agree turfed him out left him open go on
raptured get out sling your rook yeah
now he's going to go to america to face
hacking charges so i've got logan paul's
dog died it's not really the same as it
yes no it really isn't this is the thing
about true news a bit like a box of
chocolates you never know what you're
gonna get what's your favorite line from
forrest gump probably life is it's like
a box of chocolates i don't know what
you're gonna get i like it when his
mother realizes he's a bit of a done so
he fails the iq test
and she goes there must be something
can't be done about three little points
now the headmaster goes over to her
house and blatantly [__] her and when
he comes out that was sort of forest is
just on his little tree swing and the
headmaster goes to him your mama sure
does care about your schooling boy that
is horrible this is donald trump uh now
over previous weeks we've been taking
other uh [__] [__] politicians to
task well here's the king of them
wikileaks on wikileaks through wikileaks
in wikileaks now wikileaks that's
wikileaks
uh i know nothing about wikileaks it's
not my thing he is one of the greatest
bullshitters of a generation though
slogan paul's dog died you know logan's
a big character on the internet and uh
people seem to love his dog he had two
points something million instagram
followers which is more than us
annoyingly oh he's such a little cute
look at that so this he was in the yard
and apparently some coyotes came and you
know california's like he called it uh
kong the savage the dog
in an ironic way i think you recount
some lovely memories you've made your
den in this universe and i wouldn't have
expected you to go any other way no that
didn't make me giggle a little bit like
i wouldn't have expected you to go any
other way
at the moment
i remember when i held you as a pup and
i thought you're going to get taken by a
coyote one day
it's it's the awkwardness in which we we
talk about death that means we giggled
sometimes but um yeah r.i.p
very sad do you find it a little bit
weird when a dog has three million
followers i'd kind of rather a dog have
three million followers than some of
these [__] i can get behind the dog i
can't get behind the toilet i mean i've
seen you behind plenty of [__] before
we went on we were listening to some
music yeah do you know there's something
come out about our old rap heroes young
book i think young book might have a
thing for women with penises basically
this person here put something out on
instagram alluding to the fact that
she'd slept with young book he rang her
up and she recorded the phone call if
he'd have just ignored this
then it would have all gone away because
there's no [__] evidence there's a
lesson to be learned here if you do
happen to like
just anyone check me out what i'm saying
that's the conversation to have for
another time at this point cause i want
to let it out and i want to tell you why
i did i want you to understand why
just have to take two thousand dollars
and flip that [__] so many ways and i
could be rich off two thousand dollars
so basically oh she's recording the call
young book is offering her two thousand
dollars to remove the instagram post
thousands that's nothing i know but he
hasn't got the money he used to have oh
50. 50 cents is going to laugh at you at
this point on instagram sorry i've got a
transgender woman who i [__] who's
holding me ransom for money on instagram
can you pay her hello 50 hello dude do
you realize what you did yes i'm telling
you i'm
too you're not the only one she's
basically a sad little [__] and i have
no sympathy for when she says people are
attacking me too yeah because you put a
picture up or whatever you did which
outed young buck the type of people he
probably knows he's got a better way of
spending that 2000. well she wants to
ruin lives i mean there's just there's a
simple scenario for that if you're that
kind of person isn't it i think if
someone tries to ruin your life and
you've already been down that road and
go back down that road right yeah that's
my thing because that she is [__]
poisoned her like i ain't got a problem
with no gay people
whatever the [__] you [__] thought you
seen on the tape [__] that ain't no
[__] tape with no [__]
punk sucking my dick [__] ass [__] why
don't you just pull up and keep that
same energy [__] you give me the
location i'll give you the location keep
that same energy and say all this old
whole ass [__] that you want to say on
the grim say it to my face we can do it
on the lab too you bitch-ass [__] so
he's gone on the phone rang her up she's
recorded that she's then put that out to
prove that he's guilty now people are
laughing at him openly young book was in
the gangster rap group of the 2000s like
yeah he was seen as a hard rapper i feel
sorry because now he's out here just
offering anyone out like just totally
losing his [__] it's kind of unfortunate
because if this would say happened back
in the day before instagram and social
media just you know before all this
stuff came out he probably could have
like kept it quiet uh speaking of music
the uk's number one youtuber in numbers
obviously we're
they're pretty good ksi has got a new
album with his good mate randall
called new age so ksi put a tweet out to
let everyone know that if you want to
use our youtube music in your youtube
videos go ahead we in copyright claiming
anything we want to let everyone eat
this is a new age use the title of the
branding we're fully independent we make
our own rules enjoy the album jake paul
replied of all people well-known
copyright lawyer jake paul yeah he says
ah hey i [__] with this idea bro i've
been on that same [__] i'mma do this too
i'm tired of artists being greedy this
is the start of a change respect bro jj
replied shut the [__] up you [__] jake
paul there just slammed
by yeah
that is a hell of a reply they are never
going to be friends all this let's check
the album out this is the new age
now they want to play because they're
trying to get paid but they can't
because they're too late i like that
song and i think that is one of
randolph's best verses like he carries
that song well one thing i do like about
on the whole album having listened to it
is the switch in the instrumental style
between when randolph wraps and when jj
raps so randall's like this right but
now it changes
[__] you big boy with that big proof
yeah i just love that his first words on
the album are yeah yeah yeah yeah [__]
you yeah they work well together because
they do sound very different my favorite
song on the album so far is beerus but
maybe it's because i've already heard it
quite a few items because i just like
that beat can we hear that you don't
like me that's established
[Music]
you should be embarrassed i like changes
but sure i'm a godlike beerus
i'm a god like beerus made my mind light
over mars i don't see nobody coming
nearer i like jj's voice i don't think
jj is ever gonna be like a lyrical
rapper like that's not his thing what do
you think he is more of an impact
yeah i think his voice is what is going
to give him the best chance of like
making really successful songs i think
randolph lyrically was quite impressive
on the um so far obviously
to listen like twice i'll tell you one
criticism i've got so far a lot of the
songs sound the same but obviously it's
the same two rappers every time so
that's about happening a little bit but
like the beats and that like some of
them sound similar the one where minnie
mint has girlfriends taliamar is her
name that was a nice like break
yeah i thought that was good youtube was
branching out we're always going to
support that so good luck with them
there's a lot of good tracks on the
album i think all 10 of them have got
their own individual stuff featuring
someone like jamie on there gives it a
little bit yeah jeremy delivers what
you'd expect he just comes in and tears
it up on the lyrics that's out now if
you want to check that out at the lads
with a cut off their latest album it's
case i'm randolph they're not here um
yeah one day i had them in the kitchen
and i had them in the kitchen legendary
wrestler bret the hitman heart was in
the middle of giving a speech for the
hall of fame and uh he just got attacked
by someone in the crowd
so wwe cut it live on air yeah yeah
thank god they didn't have a knife or
anything on them otherwise you would
have been [__] bro obviously in his
dear would have probably kicked the [__]
out of this guy he was one of the few
wrestlers who you think yeah you'd know
some [__] you go for someone in their
prime not a 61 year old cancer um
survivor and stroke victim ronda
rousey's husband travis brown ufc
heavyweight was on hand to deliver
plenty of punches to the head of the
market yeah that's unfortunately tried
that on so good on travis sproul do you
think yeah [__] that guy if you're on
stage or you're in an event like that
and you decide to rush are you prepared
to get the hell beaten out well we hope
that the guy recovers well i know it can
be a traumatic thing to tackle a famous
wrestleman punch in the face repeatedly
by a ufc heavyweight that must have been
quite the day yeah but he woke up
hangover this is a little news story up
next up really touched my heart laurence
eating vaginal fluids makes you immune
to cancer and other diseases uh
scientists at st austin university in
north carolina investigate the benefits
of vaginal or cervical mucus consumption
and the results were amazing can i just
say i can't find the fat i've been
eating [__] for a long time never had
cancer if you're a man and you sort of
don't want to do that it's imperative
you do it for yourself improved
is [__] great last week we had tony
ferguson uh sort of reported by his wife
to the police unfortunately another
ufc legend bj penn has been reported by
his wife now the ufc hall of famer had a
restraining order placed on him by the
state of hawaii on behalf of the mother
of his children so this isn't just like
a girlfriend or nothing you know like
she alleged a wide range of verbal and
physical threats and abuse
ranging from a string of incidents um
she said that he had a drug problem and
that he would use fighting to
keep him off the drugs japan is a bit of
a hero but he was one of my first like
ufc yeah i remember fighters who i used
to love he fought in newcastle yeah that
is really sad apparently it's his
statement um the statement has been
released by his team bj is in a highly
contested child custody case involving
his two young daughters the order of
protection has made serious allegations
against him the allegations are
misleading hurtful and false any further
comment about bj would cause more damage
to the well-being of his children so
basically bj penn's family have asked
them to respect their privacy at this
time sad when divorce happens
children are being sort of fought over
things that have happened in the
relationship or even haven't happened
the relationship start coming out and it
just gets worse and worse and worse you
would hope they can find a way to just
say yeah look whatever has happened
happened if she doesn't trust him and
rightly doesn't trust them around the
kids then fair enough then things need
to be done but i do not you hope they
can come to some sort of agreement where
this doesn't have to get worse and worse
and worse tj dillashaw i would say in in
his prime arguably one of the best
fighters in the ufc yeah has just tested
positive for performance enhancing drugs
which has sort of started a big debate
hasn't it yeah um it's epo that he's
tested positive for which is what a lot
of the cyclists used to take back in the
day and it just makes you have insane
cardio it's one thing to cheat when
you're
throwing
basketballs into a hoop or playing a
sport but when you're fighting and
you're getting an advantage that could
kill someone or really hurt someone it's
bang out of order then but interestingly
the strength and conditioning coach i'm
not saying that this is the guy who gave
him it but
usually performance coaches are the ones
who offer up the performance enhancing
drugs that's not really the martial arts
guys you are going to come and go do you
want some gear it's usually the weight
lifter you also say that if you are a
performance coach and your fighter
starts performing well you go bloody job
well done my training is paying off um
because with a heavy heart that i coach
carl the founder and the purveyor of the
training lab is sorry is a heavy heart
sort of a side effect of epo or is that
maybe he's on the juice i've recently
seen a defeat in one of our family
members in a few months this defeat is
not due to the skills and combat savvy
of an opponent of flesh but rather a
defeat at the perilous hands of a far
more sinister foe the demon of
self-doubt which haunts each and every
one of us at one time or another in our
lives and what that means yeah one time
or another we're all going to be a
victim of this because that's what he
really is lawrence a victim of
self-doubt he is a victim of the human
mind but he's not he's not he's just a
cheat who's trying to get an advantage
to beat other people at fighting that's
what he really is this guy's a [__]
he basically said you know what he did
wasn't right that being said we would
also like to thank those who have come
forward at this time to show their
genuine concern about all of our
athletes especially tj
a fallen soldier on the battlefield of
public expectation and demand for
perfection tj succumbed to the
relentless pressure to win at any cost
for the purposes of appeasing his
employers and pleasing his fan base what
he's saying is i think you should you
lost him for tj to the show putting a
needle in his arse cj put a statement
out basically a video of him just going
yeah
just got to suck this up and uh just
gotta suck this up and get on with the
next two years i guess i'm just gonna do
a few uh surgeries he apologized to his
fans and his family at no point did he
apologize to the men he'd beaten up
while juice to the [__] gills getting
an unfair advantage on them and
therefore knocking them unconscious i
would love for them to remake the the
next fight tj versus cody without tj on
the [__] epo and for cordy to just
smash the living [__] out yeah is this
her no we can't do her again can we i
just wanted to check oh what is she
doing no man that does look amazing is
that just like boiled cheese i mean it's
probably mixed in a milk you need that
much cheese on on meatballs i mean i'm
yeah you do really oh jesus
oh god
we've seen enough we had this sent into
us i like when you like get involved in
the show this is a community we're
building up here
we've got the true news the true use as
well and use a lot of scent this is
probably a good name for them welcome
back the true use
hey guys billy here and today
um
i've got a video where
i didn't think i was gonna make a video
on sunday but it just came in my head ah
i suppose i won't make any videos on
sunday i should make a video it's sunday
yes yeah it just happened yeah it's a
brushless chicken sandwich yeah i'm just
gonna let it cool down cause it's gonna
be a bit hot
i didn't expect as i said i didn't
expect to make a video today out of
breath
he seems a bit puggered by this whole i
don't know if it's the pressure being on
camera we'll let him say one thing i
really love is he keeps saying i didn't
expect i didn't expect to make videos
there he's treating this video like he's
accepting an oscar i didn't think of it
i'm prepared to speak i don't i didn't
expect to get an oscar but he loves me
you you really love really what sort of
youtube videos do you think you'd have
made when you were i was heavy into
gaming when i was 12. i loved gaming
what console you mainly on ps3
playstation 2 i think uh playstation one
two i would have been sort of eating a
packet of biscuits gaming being 12 and
13 was really hard for me oh you just
got through that puberty bit on you and
it's all quick
i'm just gonna have my birthday go go go
and then go for a meal then i'm gonna
hopefully go for a chelsea season like
chelsea stadium tour i wonder if i
wonder if he likes chelsea rory yeah
well we might find out sorian yeah sorry
i'm gonna try it now i think it's warm
enough
he's basically started the camera too
early hold it like that hold it because
it's not hot i've never seen such an
awkward silence on a on a youtube video
before oh don't burn your phone son
i'm not sure i put i put it in the
microwave for how long it said let's
have another bite see if it's any nicer
we'll now wait another 30 seconds while
they choose put a little bit of ksi and
randolph in yeah
[Music]
a youtuber called the blue van man
unreal unreal the matrix we're living in
the [__] matrix of food reviews the
blue van man is influencing the youth of
today the youth of today washington
going that guy's [__] cool i've got
to do some [__] like this i wasn't
expecting to do a video today but
suddenly there is a charge in my body to
make it
junior he was the one that
started older a few food reviews he
started food reviews he literally
invented the concept but before that no
one else never expressed an opinion on
food they'd just gone
mm-hmm are you gonna eat that yeah yeah
whatever i said is that good yeah no one
ever asked that question and no one ever
got the tail yeah
he's funny we want him to get more
subscribers to help him grow i mean
let's start growing channels constantly
why not i'm trying to regret some of the
previous ones um
why not billy blight head over there
take a look in the meantime let's look
at probably the most influential fun man
a lot of you people out there oh my god
he's dressing like you just appear
allowed to meet just a pair of loud
spirits just showing their cleavage off
just show you cleavage let me just turn
my chair around
i've got them stools where you've got
the steps on it
and if i don't put my feet on the step
i'm going to bend the
bar that goes across the neck right oh
done it again can i just literally could
have started the video again this is
about buck fuss tonic wine we're 30
seconds in right now into a 17 minute
video this is the thing about youtube
right once people get into this editing
like we try and make longer videos but
you don't get this kind of quality very
rarely on youtube not this compressed
people oh he's putting a lot into this
yeah we need to get him a new camera
but fast we didn't know that was coming
because of the title but i didn't know
when it was coming or where lovely
surprise yeah exactly it's a bit like um
a horror movie you know there's a bad
guy in it but you don't know where he's
going to come from ha ha yeah
no one expects breakfast so all my
scottish uh
friends out there um
this goes out to you uh scotty uh used
to own the pub down the village
out of a public work absolutely eleven
public used to really buzz and then uh
scotty and margaret uh left and uh it
went [__]
you and i love a good red wine that
doesn't look good does it no i'll be
honest it worries me
i tell you what though folks that's
bloody nice that is bloody lovely scotty
why don't you sell this down there why
don't you sell it down the pub imagine
right yuri's wife you're over here and
you don't know he's recording in the in
the garage or whatever you still put
your ear next to the the door you just
heard him in the garage call scotty why
did you suddenly stone the pub oh lovely
place and then you just you pick your
head in and he's just talking to his
camera he's just holding but you can't
see the camera he's just holding a
bottle in mid-air he's really lost it
what's we're going after she's probably
got one of her friends over and they're
in the living room and every now and
again they just get a waft of his voice
and and she just goes just keeps him
busy just keeps him busy doing it yeah
let him do his youtube thing seems to be
going well for him i've said it was
going well well alf was watching it
other day he said he bloody loved it
yeah everyone's watching the owner ask
your dad why didn't sell it
this is a direct address
to these people and yeah this has got 53
000 views and he's going [__] up
on that why did he
right folks i have come in for a wet
shave where am i mate what's the name of
your shot last followers
we are in loughborough so uh to help
promote local business he does look
really fun to hang out with like he
looks like he'd be a fan i love the fact
that the first thing he wants to do with
his newfound fame promote local
businesses love that he knows the effect
of brexit he knows what's going to
happen to local businesses in that he's
trying to i'd love to hear what he
thinks about brexit because i think he'd
probably get it right yeah i feel like
we should we should be negotiating the
terms right now
next week you can see blue van man
expressing all his political views oh if
you can't wait and you want to make your
own mind up and blue man just go and
check his channel out blue van man 2.0
oh well
regular as well i like that he's got a
second channel already yeah you haven't
subscribed to my channels the kickoff
football channel tg2 that's the second
channel where we do other stuff like
gaming and that way i'll be well i kind
of beat him on one race on mario and
then he came back later on but i think
that channel is now called lawrence
beats true geordie at racing it's not
it's not it's tj too oh that's awesome
so yeah check that check there mo and uh
hopefully you've enjoyed true
news with yours truly
true jordy
that's us truly uh
don't forget if you have any big stories
send them to us and we can more than
yeah we can put them in uh just tweet us
whatever
um and yeah we'll see you next week have
a good one they're gone totally clicked
off
already already clicked off so oh you
missed the trick yeah yeah should i have
this in the pricks
there's going to be merch soon ha ha
tricked trick
probably yeah that's fine we're gonna go
for lunch now so see you later